et une crise sanitaire qui a réveillé le
mal être de beaucoup de salariés
également dont ceux de l'enseigné
carrefour ils étaient nombreux à
répondre à l'appel de la cgt cfdt pour
une grève nationale
aujourd'hui 70 à 80 hypermarchés
pourraient être concernés sur les
quelque 200 que compte le groupe a calé
à marseille et près de toulouse une
cinquantaine de salariés sont venus
dénoncer l'attitude à de la direction
écouter les conditions de travail se
dégradent les salaires n'augmentaient
pas comme il faudrait
et donc bien sûr il ya une désarroi qui
se crée tout simplement
on est en train de nous on va dire de
nous presser combinaison arena tout
simplement et c'est pour ça que les gens
ne sont pas sont là aujourd'hui 4,5
millions d'euros seront distribués aux
actionnaires en cache cette fois-ci même
pas un stock options et notre
gouvernement vient de reconduire la
possibilité d'avoir la fameuse prime
convient de la prime maquereau ou la
prime paie pas et aujourd'hui nous avons
envoyé toutes les organisations
syndicales des courriers pour pouvoir en
bénéficier
il me semble que les résultats de
l'entreprise sont liés au travail des
salariés d'un deuxième ligne ceux qui
sont sur le terrain pour l'instant la
lente reprise reste muette